[موسيقى]
لم يتوقع الايراني مهران ناصري ان معارضته
لحكومه بلده وسفره من فرنسا الى بريطانيا
ستجعله حبيس الصاله رقم واحد في مطار
شارلي جول الدولي في باريس لمده 18 عاما
وان قصته ستكون حديثه وسائل الاعلام
لسنوات وستلهم صناع السينما في هوليود فما
قصته بدات معاناه مهران المولود في ايران
في العام
1942 عندما كان طالبا في جامعه البريطانيه
وشارك في مظاهره طلابيه ضد حكومه بلاده في
العام 1970 فقبض عليه عند عودته لايران في
العام
1974 ثم تم نفيه من ايران بعد تخليه عن
جواز سفره في العام
1977 ليحصل بعدها على اللجوء من قبل
مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في
بلجيكا في العام
1981 فب في بلجيكا لسبع سنوات وقرر بعدها
الذهاب الى بريطانيا وفي الثامن من اغسطس
من العام
1988 عندما كان مهران مسافرا من مطار
شارلي جول في فرنسا الى مطره في بريطانيا
سرقت منه حقيبه سفره التي كانت تحوي
اوراقه ثبوتيه والخاصه باللجوء اضافه الى
مستندات قانونيه وتم ارجاعه الى مطار
تشارلي جول وما زاد الطين بالله ان مهران
لم تكن لديه قدره على احضار اوراق بديله
من بلجيكا لتلك التي سرقت منه حتى يتمكن
من اثباته في مطار شارلي جول كلاجه وما
حدث كان بدايه قصه مثيره تم منع مهران من
مغادره الصاله رقم واحد في المطار حتى تتم
تسويه وضعها مره السنوات وبقي مهران في
المطار بجانب حقائبئه التي توحي بانك على
وشك السفر في اي لحظه وكان يقضي وقته في
قراءه الكتب وتسجيل مذكراته ليصبح مهران
رمزا من رموز المطار فتهافتت عليه الصحف
وقنوات الاخبار لاجراء المقابلات معه وفي
العام
1999 حصل مهران واخيرا على وثائق جديده
وتم منحه اذنا للخروج من المطار والسفر
بحريه الى اي جزء من اوروبا لكن لم تنتهي
المشكله هنا فمهران الناصري رفض الرحيل
بسبب ادراج جسمه في الوثائق على انه
ايرانيه وما كان يريده هو الحصول على
الجنسيه البريطانيه وان يسجل على انه
بريطانيا ظلم مهران على هذا الحال حتى
العامي 2006 عندما اصيب مهران بوعكه صحيه
استدعت نقله الى احد مستشفيات باريس ومن
ثم انتقل الى مركز للايواء في العاصمه
ليغادر صاله رقم واحد بعد انقض فيها 18
عاما الهمت قصه مهران صناع السينما في
هوليود فقام المخرج الامريكي ستيفن
بالبركه في العام 2004 باخراج فيلم
تيرمينال الذي كانت تدور احداثه عن رجل
اضطر الى العيش داخل مطار جون كينيدي في
نيويورك وكام ببطوله الفيلم الممثل
الامريكي توم هانكس نال الفيلم شهره واسعه
ولا يزال مهران في مركز الايواء في باريس
[موسيقى]